Okay, you ready to get some hair done?
This is a little more slippery than I expected.
You just go through.
Okay.
So you can pause and you can read your own video.
You can pause basically with space bars.
You can start.
Okay.
So I just speak to you?
Yep.
Delightfully so.
Yeah, I think at the beginning I'm pretty calm.
Yeah, ready to start.
Yeah, I think at that moment I realized the area is a bit different from what I'm used to.
It's a little more slippery.
So I try to focus on it and control.
My pitford better.
I think so far it's fine, but here.
Yeah, I stopped on the wrong bit.
So I kind of fixed it.
Yeah, so I made some adjustment along the way.
The level of power I exerted.
I kind of.
Reduce a bit.
To have a better balance.
And then I think the flow is fine.
But yeah, if I have better balance, I might do a little bit more strength or power on some of the moves.
Yeah, this is towards the end and I feel mostly good.
But yeah, there's some moves that I adjusted along the way.
Okay.
Okay, thank you.
Yeah.
You get it.
On how you're scored.
As you can see, your pattern is scored based on the number 10, so out of 10 is your 1.
As you can see, it's...